non
aussi loin que je me souvienne je me
suis toujours dit on avait besoin de
changer le monde
alors c'est pas comme à l'origine des
ted où je me disais que je voulais
révolutionner le monde quand j'étais un
enfant je me disais juste la lettre qui
vont pas et chacun d'entre nous on a
peut-être le moyen de faire avancer un
petit peu les choses
ma notion de changer le monde c'est ni
d'être connu une idée triche c'est
d'aider son prochain à avancer dans ma
carrière j'ai eu de la chance j'ai aidé
des tables entrepreneurs à comprendre un
peu mieux leurs idées à profiter un
petit peu de mon expérience je continue
à le faire
et pourtant j'ai pas eu de mentor
j'ai pas une mentor mais j'ai eu
beaucoup mieux que ça j'ai grandi avec
ce monsieur qui était un geek avant qu
on appelle ça un geek moins geeks
connaissement l'appui une dizaine
d'années et mon père lui c'était un mec
qui était un curieux alors c'était pas
un geek c'était un mec qui aimait à mes
anniversaires venir avec un cinéma et je
trouvais ça génial mes potes trouvé ça
génial j'en ai au fond de la salle ils
trouvaient ça génial de pouvoir faire un
cinéma à la maison mon père il nous
filmaient quand on était petit alors on
fait tout ça il montait ses films une
époque où fallait le faire avec des
ciseaux ou fallait couper les bandes et
les coller il n'y avait pas là et movie
avait pas de mac
personnellement j'aurais jamais fait un
truc pareil c'était juste pas possible
il m'enseignait un truc qu'un mentor
aurait pas pu la prendre quand je suis
petit quand j'étais petit il m'a appris
est curieux avoir ce goût de commandes
sont construites les choses et comment
je pouvais peut-être moins à les
construire
alors j'ai pas changer le monde j'ai
commencé par faire des lego
j'ai commencé par jouer j'ai encore des
stocks de lego à la maison maintenant
ils sont dans la cave j'ai plus trop le
temps mais j'adore ça et j'ai commencé à
construire des choses j'ai commencé à
apprendre comment fonctionnaient les
choses m'intéressent air dans un
environnement à 10 ans même pas
d'ailleurs à 7 ans il m'a acheté un
amstrad cpc 464
alors les mecs qui ont plus de 30 ans à
peut-être de quoi je parle et surtout
vous remarqué le petit truc sur le côté
c'est une cassette ça marchait avec des
cassettes
alors les moins de 20 ans jamais vu une
cassette de leur vie d'abord parce que
ça sert plus à rien et puis toute façon
le magnétoscope aujourd'hui sert plus à
rien ben moi j'ai appris sur des
ordinateurs ou à l'époque fallait
attendre 30 minutes
deux lancers sur le programme parce que
la cassette elle elle tournait tout
doucement et que c'est comme ça qu'on
lançait un programme
bon alors à sept ans j'ai pas prêt à
crever comme david l'a dit j'ai appris à
17 ans mais surtout je me suis posé des
questions je me suis posé la question de
caisse que j'avais envie de construire
et comment je pouvais le construire à 17
ans j'ai appris à coder alors à l'époque
c'étaient des livres on appelait ça des
bibles je sais pas pourquoi peut-être à
cause du poids
c'était des bouquins de 400 pages
minimum 10 minimum parce que c'était
vraiment le minimum y avait des bouquins
qu'ils aient plusieurs tonnes et fallait
lire 200 pages très théorique avant de
pouvoir afficher ce qu'on appelle hello
world le premier truc qu'on vous apprend
à pêcher
sincèrement j'ai fait des nuits blanches
j'ai fait des semaines entières à
m'arracher la tête
maintenant j'ai des cheveux mais à
l'époque c'était dur est vraiment
vraiment c'était dur vraiment c'était
dur d'apprendre à coder à cette époque
là j'ai grandi enfin j'ai grandi je lui
ai dit que j'étais dire un peu vieux
j'ai monté des entreprises j'ai eu
beaucoup d'expériences différentes varié
avec des gens passionnants il m'est
arrivé un truc je vais pas dire qu'il
était pas prévu ce petit bout de chou
est arrivé dans ma vie il ya 21 mois
elle est ce qu'on appelle un digital
natives c'est à dire que grosso modo
vous voyez j'ai pris cette photo hier
soir je pouvais pas mieux illustrer mon
propos
elle a 20 mois tous les soirs tout le
matin aussi d'ailleurs elle veut
appliquer mon iphone elle celle des look
et elle sait aller chercher ces vidéos
elle sait pas lire mais elle sait
comment les trouver ces applications
elle c'est dans l'application comment
les trouver sa vidéo sa chanson celle
qu'elle a envie d'écouter maintenant et
ça c'est un truc de digital natives et
je me suis dit tout bêtement alors je
connais mon évolution
mais quelle va être la sienne qu'est ce
qu'elle va faire dans 30 ans dans quel
monde
elle va vivre dans 30 ans aujourd'hui
c'est facile de regarder derrière et de
se dire ben alors il ya trente ans il ya
eu premier mac
on est un peu nostalgique du mec de tout
ça le premier bébé l'arrivée enfin
plutôt la disparition de la cassette
pour moi c'était une bonne nouvelle
voilà toutes ces choses là je me suis
vraiment posé la question de voir ce
qu'on valait d'entre eux alors dans 30
ans il aura peut-être mao enfin en fait
il y aura les petits frères de now now
aujourd'hui moi j'ai eu la chance de
jouer avec gens n'ayant pas journée au
bureau et j'ai eu la chance de le faire
danser de lui faire faire des trucs et
ce qui est sympa avec now c'est que
quand on va sur un salon quand on va
dans un lieu public
dès que les gens voient now ils sont
super curieux il adore ma peau et c'est
un truc très futuriste now aujourd'hui
on n'a pas encore de robots à la maison
on a des robots ménagers
c'est déjà une première forme de robot
mais un robot à qui on envie va me
chercher une bière au frigo et qui
revient avec la bière des bouchonné
fraîche et en voile attendant avec
presque un sourire ça on n'a pas encore
dans 30 ans évidemment il aurait des
robots comme ça aujourd'hui now il sait
déjà le faire le grand frère de now
enfin la grande soeur peppers et c'est
déjà faire tout un tas de choses là où
c'est un peu la vitrine marketing
d'aldébaran la société qu'il a
développés qui ne société française
d'ailleurs on est un peu chauvin est en
fait derrière ça ils ont développé des
applications qui sont beaucoup plus
utiles entre lee mais aujourd'hui il ya
des robots qui sont capables d'aller
aider des personnes qui sont capables
d'aller dans un champ de mil pour
détecter les mines et sauter à la place
d'un soldat si nécessaire il ya aussi
des robots qui sont capables c'est aussi
france est de permettre à un médecin à
new york d'opérer un malade à paris et
personnellement pour la lutherie frier
le cerveau il faut vraiment je sois
obligé de laisser un mec faire ça et
encore plus s'il à dix mille kilomètres
aujourd'hui c'est une réalité j'ai du
mal à imaginer situera dans 30 ans mais
il ya un sujet qui m'intéresse c'est les
voitures
j'aime bien les voitures qui me
connaissent savent j'aime bien conduire
les voitures
malheureusement la tendance pendant le
heureusement entre guillemets c'est que
les voitures de demain nous aurons plus
de conducteurs
alors on parle beaucoup de conduite sans
chauffeur de toutes les petites
évolutions
il ya des projets européens d'ailleurs
qui vont un peu dans le sens là vous
arrivez sur l'autoroute la voiture prend
le relais et tout se fait tout seul il
ya des choses qui existent depuis cinq
six ans dans vos voitures c'est le fait
qu'elle puisse se garer toute seule
on a toujours considéré que le truc le
plus dur dans la voiture c'était de se
garer
bon moi je trouve pas mais bon après qu
en réalité la vraie question qui se pose
derrière ça imaginez ce qui se passera
dans 30 ans dans dix ans dans 20 ans
dans dix ans dans 20 ans 30 ans on va
avoir des voitures qui vont se tenir
tout seul peut-être des bus qui vont se
produire tout seul on va monter dedans
on va lui dire voilà ahmed mois à tel
endroit
il va vous emmener un tel endroit ça va
juste totalement changé notre rapport
aux transports personnellement ce que
j'attends c'est qu'on puisse se tait les
transporter c'est encore une autre étape
j'ai pas trouvé une boîte qui faisait ça
pour les guides qui sont dans la salle
j'ai trouvé une boîte qui arrive à faire
des hologrammes
le truc de star wars au début avec ça ça
existe déjà j'ai déjà vu ça et c'est
déjà pas mal
c'est déjà un bon début mais toute la
question c'est de savoir en fait comment
on peut faire ça
comment pr nous prendre le contrôle là
dessus au jour d'aujourd'hui
ma fille elle va aller dans une école
bientôt du encore un peu petit où on
n'apprend pas ça où on n'apprend pas
l'informatique on n'apprend pas le code
c'est quelque chose qui est encore très
loin alors quand je vous parle de code
je pense qu'il y en a beaucoup qui
pensent à ça qu'ils se disent un truc
c'est des hiéroglyphes
j'y comprends rien et c'est un peu vrai
c'est un peu la réalité c'est que ça
ressemble plutôt à ça
le code ces démos généralement en
anglais vous les mettez ensemble ça fait
un truc lancer des mots qui veulent pas
forcément dire ce que vous voulez faire
mais ça va le faire
c'est un peu l'idée c'est un truc un peu
barbare c'est de l'anglais sans l'aide
de l'anglais d'ailleurs on appelle ça le
langage informatique c'est pas pour rien
c'est une langue en soit je vais pas
vous parler tous les langages
informatiques
sinon on encore là demain mais ils
codent en soit c'est surtout en fait ça
le code pour moi khlie code depuis
maintenant quelques années c'est avant
tout de l'art c'est pas une façon de
faire des lignes et taper quelque chose
sur mon clavier c'est pas non plus une
façon de d'être derrière un ordinateur à
passer à faire quelque chose de
rébarbatif
- quand je serai un programme et j'en
suis fier j'ai fait ma monna lisa
vraiment
je suis fier d'avoir créé une oeuvre
d'art quand je vais je vais discuter
avec quelqu'un chez aldebaran ou
ailleurs d'ailleurs qui a construit now
et qui a été capable de le programmer
pour faire des choses utiles aux autres
ou pas d'ailleurs
danser je suis pas sûr que ça soit 13
buts et mais c'est une oeuvre d'art je
le pense profondément
le code ça peut vous aider à quoi ça
peut vous aider à vous aider dans vos
tâches quotidiennes
je connais énormément de gens qui
travaillent sur l'excellent tous les
joueurs qui font des tâches ultra
rébarbative très répétitives ennuyeuse
je veux dire que ça ait en fait -
généralement quand j'arrive avec deux
lignes de code
bah je leur fais genre permet de faire
en deux minutes chaque jour ce qu'ils
font en quatre heures tous les ans ça
peut aussi vous aider à être
millionnaire
bon je vais pas m'éterniser là dessus il
ya un mec qui voulait rencontrer des
filles il a créé facebook pas mal c'est
une petite boîte
ça peut aussi vous avez à changer le
monde alors peut-être que facebook
twitter youtube ont changé le monde
peut-être que hayden musk avec tesla en
créant les voitures électriques de
demain va changer le monde
peut-être que moi on est dans le petit
mec qu'avec à développer la bonne idée
et qui va vous la présenter dans un an
deux ans peut-être que je les ai aidé un
peu à changer le monde
ce que je veux dire surtout c'est que
chacun d'entre nous peut aller vers ça
au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est pas ça
l'informatique s'est pas créé quelque
chose
enfin en fait si c'est ça c'est pas
créer un terminator c'est créer quelque
chose de toute pièce qui n'existent pas
alors la version plus sympathique c'est
ça
y'a des filles dans la salle en fait
pourquoi je vous montre terminator est
pourquoi je montre au lycée parce que là
il ya une satisfaction particulière qu
un codeur déconner ou qu'un artiste
connaît c'est la satisfaction d'arriver
à trouver quelque chose à la fin de son
produit ça à la fin du processus de
création
on a quelque chose de concret on voit
quelque chose il ya quelque chose qui
existe alors dans cadre d'un programme
c'est peut-être pas palpable mais ça
existe comme vous la connaissez
peut-être pas non quelqu'un l'a connaît
même pas semblant
elle s'appelle ada lovelace elle est
considérée comme la première avoir créé
un programme informatique
alors j'aime bien parler d'elle pour une
raison toute simple
la première c'est que je suis dans un
métier d'hommes en tout cas on essaye de
le faire croire que c'est dans un métier
d'homme je vois pas pourquoi une femme
serait pas capable de créer un programme
informatique
la plupart des femmes que je connais
sont largement aussi intelligente que
nous sommes voire plus
on va pas lancer ce débat là
personnellement je suis pour l'égalité
c'était pas pour lancer le débat s'était
plus tôt pour dire que au contraire
l'informatique est hérité de cette femme
là elle a créé ce qu'on appelle le
progrès premier programme informatique
en 1843 aux ingénieurs en 1843 n'est pas
l'ordinateur
effectivement le premier ordinateur
c'est celui-là en 1943 alors il ya eu
des prémices on va en parler après et en
fait ce premier ordinateur il permettait
de faire quoi il permettait sur un
calcul
alors il prenait la sla la taille d'à
peu près 700 même plus il pesait capital
et demi il permettait de faire une
opération de mathématiques que n'importe
qui pouvait faire avec une feuille de
papier faut être hyper flemmards quand
même pour passer des années à développer
un truc comme ça pour faire un truc
qu'on aurait pu faire en 10 secondes
personnellement je connais beaucoup de
programmeurs et entre nous on se le dit
le programmeur et sans doute l'être
humain les mares il est capable de
passer dix mois a développé un truc qui
va lui faire gagner 5 secondes
mais il ya des satisfactions au bout
j'arrête les clichés promis ce que je
voulais vous dire surtout c'est que le
premier ordinateur
il permettait pas de faire grand chose
alors je vais vous montrer juste un tout
petit peu une petite aparté l'évolution
de l'informatique tels que vous la
connaissez
alors le 1 c'est la référence
1 / 1 milliard ce milliardaire et le
milliard c'est un milliard en 1920 les
premiers bribes d'ordinateurs femme
était de faire du calcul manuel c'était
l'équivalent de ce que nous aujourd'hui
une main on est capable de faire en
terme de calcul manuel en 1950 donc
après l'ordinateur qui pèse cape town
c'est un peu ça s'est un peu développée
en 1970 ça c'est encore un développés on
a eu des ordinateurs qu'ils avaient le
niveau de penser d'une bactérie
c'est choquant
une bactérie quoi bon remarquez que ça
c'est clair quand même bible en 1990
tout le monde était à peu près n'est
vous donnez pas le coup de vieux les
ordinateurs avaient le niveau d'un ver
de terre
certes le mach 2 on trouve tout génial
le libé m le premier ibm qui est
l'ancêtre de l'informatique moderne
ainsi de suite il avait niveau d'un ver
de terre alors présenté comme ça c'est
pas super sexy mais c'est quand même un
milliard de choix mieux que 70 ans en
2000 entre approche c'est le lézard on
avait des ordinateurs cavé niveau de
penser dans les arts donc grosso modo
windows 95 98
enfin ces niveaux de penser dans les
arts ce qu'on a fait le traitement de
texte début de la programmation le début
de la programmation objet l'arrivée
d'internet les a pas super héros
aujourd'hui ça s'est un peu développé et
on les ordinateurs en la puissance à peu
près de calcul d'un singe et ça veut
dire que les ordinateurs d'aujourd'hui
commence à avoir la puissance de calcul
qui permet de d'entamer de la réflexion
on estime qu'en 2020 les ordinateurs
seront aussi puissants que les hommes je
reviens pas sur la salle de terminator
tombait un peu compris l'idée c'est
surtout ce qu'il faut retenir de ce
slide c'est d'abord que les ordinateurs
sont moins puissants parce qu'on espère
et que jusqu'à il y a dix ans un
ordinateur c'était juste une série de
fonctions qui faisait seulement ce qu'on
lui demande aujourd'hui un ordinateur
c'est un objet qui est capable de
commencer à penser c'est le début mais
on y arrive ça veut aussi dire que now
dont on vous parlait tout à l'heure
le petit robot dans 20 ans 30 ans il
sera peut-être capable de penser vous
aurez une discussion avec un robot je
vous laisse réfléchir sur toutes les
implications la déontologie tout ça on
va pas en parler maintenant il me reste
deux minutes j'ai un chrono en bas c'est
flippant
merci j'ai revenir quand même à mon
sujet de base qu'est le code et le fait
qu'aujourd'hui le code ça accessible à
tout le monde c'est pas une question
d'âge c'est pas une question de
l'éducation c'est pas une question
d'hommes ou femmes
en fait c'est plus une question aux
codes en 1400 on se demandait s'il
fallait apprendre à lire je pense
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde est
d'accord c'est quand même mieux de
savoir lire aujourd'hui vous pouvez
apprendre à coder avec angry birds si
vraiment vous n'êtes pas motivé pour
aller vous tapez la bible ce que je peux
comprendre à l'écho des avec une grille
burns ma fille elle va apprendre à côté
avec la reine des neiges
c'est évident les mecs pas motivée elle
donne des vrais cours cette fille sur
internet c'est gratuit pour rien alors
si j'étais américain je vous aurais
parlé d'un truc qui s'appelle hour of
god
il faut que je commence à parler vite
parce qu'alice monde qui défile à war of
gods ses 110 millions d'eur donner de
cours au début de l'année dans cent
mille écoles avec un partenariat de sang
dans 5000 écoles
c'est 10% de ce qu'on appelle en france
l'école élémentaire qui a été formé aux
états unis fort mais ça veut juste dire
qu'on leur a appris ce que c'était que
le code ça fait pas d'eux des ingénieurs
ça leur a surtout appris ce que c'était
que toucher à l'outil informatique et à
essayer de le comprendre je vais pas
faire de french bashing
parce que d'abord ça serait pas justifié
on a des champions mondiaux qui sont
français et surtout parce qu'en france
en fait en une bonne nouvelle alors
quand je préparais mon intervention
s'était pas encore le cas mais
aujourd'hui on peut le dire en septembre
prochain tous les chômeurs en france
auront accès au moc de belles classroom
c'est à dire à des cours en ligne qui
vont leur permettre d'apprendre non
seulement de com mais tout un tas
d'autres choses
ça veut dire que les chômeurs ans
aujourd'hui qui sont quand même un vrai
problème d'abord pour eux et ensuite
pour la société bas vont pouvoir se
mettre à côté je finirai juste en disant
deux choses
la première c'est que le plus grand
voyage commence par le premier pas c'est
plus difficile mais c'est comme ça qu'il
faut se lancer
la deuxième c'est que ça vous tous merci
beaucoup